hello freak [ __ ] let's go back to
that Google memo thing yeah because this
is one of the weird lines in the sand
that got crossed with this is that uh
everybody I mean everybody established a
line in the sand I should say and it was
like you thought that memo was the worst
thing you've ever read ever and that
guy's misogynist piece of [ __ ] or he
said yeah evolutionary psychology sort
of tries to explain why people why
people to certain things and like yeah
what factors what factors are
environmental and factors are hormonal
what factors do it being a male and
after what factors have to do with being
a female and there's like a lot of
studies and that guy cited a lot of
studies he talked like he it was a
really interesting thing the only thing
that I think people could find
derogatory maybe is that he said the
women are more neurotic neurotic is a
sort of a derogatory term right value
actually avert derogatory term right
it's not neurotic is like saying that
you're not handling something good yeah
right you're not you're not handling
whatever pressures the other neurotic oh
I would be calm it's implying that like
you another person handling that same
situation perhaps email would be more
calm right like that like very aware
would be the nice way of saying it
because like my wife has a lot of
anxiety but once we had a baby I was
like oh this is why because you're
responsible for this like little alien
it can die totally make sense but the
thing that guy said that that I like
when people would argue with me about it
I'd be like so do you think men and
women are the same and from there I
don't care if they're an expert if they
say there is no difference at all I'm
like my mom had her PhD and quit to
raise us as soon as she had a baby my
wife stays home with our son was an
engineer it's like it that isn't saying
that there aren't Rockstar female
engineers that have no interest in
having a child all it does is affect the
percentage right and that's always
saying is a quality of outcome versus
opportunity is really the debate and I'm
very against equality of outcome because
the legal precedent that is insane well
it becomes a real issue like you have to
find out okay what is the actual
suppression
what is stopping people from getting to
this position that happened to be female
is it because they're being suppressed
along the way is it because the way they
interact with each other is different
than the way men interact with each
other and so when men interact with them
they get upset by it there's different
rules that have to be established in
these working environments is it that
they don't want to have anything to do
with that and they would rather not
compete in one of those hostile male
driven environments is that why they
choose not to get involved or are they
someone stopping them if someone saying
hey we got to keep chicks out of here I
don't like chicks like right it would
completely depend on what's actually
happening the latter is happening well
then you got a real issue exactly but if
the former looked a very beginning one
if it's just they choose different stuff
ironically it hurts women the most like
the very qualified ones with the job
people start looking at oh my god
because they're women
you know like programming itself was
founded by a check you know but like I
don't think that actually vented COBOL
right yeah yeah like so my buddies saw I
was going on so it's called COBOL that
Lovelace oh right yeah it's like it's
not disclosing it's not saying that
women can't do it of course not all less
women are interested in doing it yes so
and if you have an equal number of men
and women then you probably like
artificially inflated the number of
women yeah less for some reason women
gravitate towards that thing in a just
as higher percentage as men do which is
really odd there's not a lot of things
where women gravitate towards it with
the same percentage of people it's the
same like like like what is I'm sure
there's a lot of fields of study I know
particularly nursing and I think a lot
of the social studies that women
gravitate towards in higher numbers
right totally like like nursing
healthcare even I think using children's
I think there's more female physicians
even that's [ __ ] maybe I read that
from some yeah like teaching children
yeah let me grab two more yeah yeah
maybe there's got to be a ton of
different jobs that females like
gravitate towards in higher percentages
we absolutely shouldn't insist
that there's an equal representation of
men in forests exactly and in you know
in interior design my brother's a
lumberjack we work we worked one woman
works with us one time yeah and she was
from Yale and like probably doing the
whole thing you know like and he
couldn't well I don't know but couldn't
climb a tree and like some women for
sure could but if you're going like
these dudes go up 200-foot trees and and
spend all day like chopping them down
it's like that isn't going to draw 50%
women it just isn't here's what's the
most hilarious thing about the Google
memo yeah it have set so many women that
they had to take time off proving the
point it's so crazy they wanted time off
so bad that they went for it they want
to play the victim so hard that they
went for it not even understanding that
it proves the point of the most
skeptical people the most skeptical
people on the side of like gone on all
of these chicks are going to be able to
pull their own weight right off these
chicks you know
and then immediately they encounter any
adversity like we need time off from a
memo handle this for remember nice
somebody talk about evolutionary
psychology and I just can't handle it I
need time away from work I'm being
attacked
Zog like they said it was time for a
female James Bond oh [ __ ] I was like I
called him I called her double-oh-seven
seven cents on the dollar and one of the
jobs Jane bond she's open to hydration
and then whether Liza's in need of a
vacation that's so fun it's like if you
take Jamie you can have a female spy
it's just going to be different tactics
you can't have a male Wonder Woman
okay okay like we got a rule can't have
a female James Bond make your own
[ __ ] detective right be James Bond
right he's a guy and I'm cool with black
Santa I am too because that shot because
that's uh Kelly's out of line I do too
she was out of line haha but fee
erratically what is luckily be black we
was living up in the North Pole Eby is
[ __ ] that's the whole point of the iron
magic there's no goddamn Sun up there
it's freezing cold yeah
like I guess outside there could be
black Santa but he would die of rickets
well I don't think that would be the
case but I think he would he would have
a real issue getting some vitamin D he
would you'd have to go get it somewhere
maybe some supplements yeah Sarah dying
to get all [ __ ] up telling them elves
hook me up dude
you know when you're building a little
toy train [ __ ] it'll be some [ __ ]
vitamin D [ __ ] the D the D else use
that Christmas magic right but make
Santa some vitamin D I can't work
duality bro yeah and then they always
bring they bring blow to the Santa's got
to stay up for two straight days Santa
does adderall like crazy rampages
listens to only techno only house music
wise making toys to crunch times like
you know all through December's frantic
yeah hoppin adderall can't leave yeah
and then and then like and everyone's
like why the presents alphabetical means
like I've got to be alphabetical how you
organized to over organize Santa went
crazy they were way too crazy but yeah
it's like if you say that there has to
be an equal outcome you're going to
sacrifice quality a point of what jobs
it would be where you have if you have a
hundred men and a hundred women once
what jobs would you have to be where you
had an equal number of men and equal
number of women that are interested in
those jobs out of a hundred like what
job would that be what do you think was
there hmm
I was in like famous I want to be famous
what about high school teacher I feel
like we're on family feud you have no
teacher I go to the richard dawson
selling food by the way no disrespect
Steve Harvey
[Applause]
[Music]